foreign
[Music]
briefing for Thursday February 16th I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
in the coming days Canadian lawmakers
are expected to pass a law that forces
digital platforms like YouTube Tick Tock
and Netflix to Showcase more Canadian
content the country already has similar
rules for television and radio but
there's a big catch a lot of Canadian
content makers don't support the change
here's Vanessa brusso who as of
Wednesday had just shy of 127 000
followers on Tick Tock I see it as
control and I don't think it's needed in
a world that we live in today that we're
so accessible all over the world joining
us from Ottawa is Wall Street Journal
reporter Paul Vieira thanks for joining
us Paul nice to see you can you give us
a little background on this law what
specifically would it require platforms
to do because Canada lives right next
door to the United States there's always
been a concern that Canadian artists
Canadian programming Canadian songs
would get shut out by the more popular
U.S programming so so starting dating
back to the 60s Canada has had rules to
ensure that Canadian artists could get
their shows on the air their music on
the radio and it was all about promoting
Canadian stories and having venues where
Canadians can tell Canadian stories now
they want that to apply online given the
growing popularity of streaming services
and digital platforms you've been
speaking with some creators who use
platforms like YouTube or Tick Tock how
do they feel about this law there's kind
of a divide here in Canada we have for
instance media producers people who
produce TV shows and movies and such who
like this law and then you have
the new Canadian digital artists these
are people who upload material up on
YouTube Tick Tock what have you and
they've been able now to eke a living on
these new platforms uh because the
algorithms they argue have allowed their
content to reach people who have an
interest in their stuff
what they worry about is the new rules
are going to force the platforms
like YouTube for instance to rewrite
their algorithms and there's a concern
that Canadian content is going to be
sent to Canadian internet users who
don't really have an interest in that so
the artist's material are going to get
fewer clicks and then that's going to
deprioritize them on the algorithm
rankings so the digital artists here
argue that they're going to in fact get
fewer viewers globally for their work if
there's fewer clicks here in Canada and
it should be noted that YouTube has said
that the proposed changes will force
them to rewrite their algorithms and
we'll see what happens with that
can you tell us specifically about some
of the content creators that you've
talked to I mean what kind of audiences
do they have now who are they attracting
as their viewers you know I've spoke for
instance to a stand-up comedian who used
to do the clubs in Canada and because of
his Tick Tock following he's now got a
U.S tour lined up and he says he would
never have gotten that kind of audience
just waiting for Canadian television to
air his stuff I spoke to a South Asian
mother in her 40s who on Tick Tock has
provided videos of her attempts to learn
skateboarding she says she's got a
pretty big Global following and that's
helped her secured marketing deals she's
worried that the changes are going to
pose a risk to Growing your Global
audience I spoke to an indigenous woman
who does not want the Canadian label and
she's worried about her audience also
not growing so that's the perspective
from the content creators how do the
platforms feel about these rules
officials for you YouTube and Tick Tock
spent a lot of time in Ottawa Canada's
capital to try to persuade policy makers
lawmakers not to go ahead and warning of
the repercussions part of their argument
was that they're going to hurt the
actual artists they're attempting to
help Netflix Disney other streaming
platforms were also in Ottawa trying to
make the case but their argument was a
bit different as they were looking for a
more flexible definition of Canadian
content they argue the rules right now
produce some head scratchers you know
that for instance the streamers
especially Netflix and Disney are
pouring a lot of money into Canada
producing
TV shows and movies with Canadian Crews
and Canadian settings and yet they're
not considered Canadian content because
the rights are owned by a foreign
company I.E American we have seen these
rules in place for a Canadian
broadcasters for TV for radio is there a
feeling that they helped Foster a
Canadian Marketplace for those Outlets
music is a rather interesting example
because those Canadian content rules for
radio came into place in the 1970s some
music historians will tell you that some
substandard content was aired for a
while but at the same time it's helped
create this ecosystem that allowed
Canadian artists to get their songs
played create a following and then
create a following in the U.S the same
applies for TV we had shows like SCTV
Second City television Kids in the Hall
and of course most recently shit's creek
there was an ecosystem in place and
because of Canadian content rules
ecosystems were allowed to flourish and
then led to the production of these
shows that later on became hits in the
U.S and globally so there is an argument
that these rules have helped the
domestic industry and there's also an
argument that these rules have also been
good economic policy in terms of
allowing for growth of the Performing
Arts sector in this country what's the
global picture for this are other
countries considering similar rules
taking similar steps this is a really
good question the platforms are worried
that if Canada goes ahead with these
plans these proposals and they're
finalized and implemented the big worry
is that individual countries will now
start to copy them and that's going to
force platforms be it streaming
companies YouTube Tick Tock it's going
to force them to write all sorts of
algorithms for individual countries and
then that sort of
poses a problem for their business model
all right that's our reporter Paul Viera
thanks for joining us Paul thank you Zoe
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]